don't know what the difference between
our Christian right and the Taliban is
what I have no idea what the difference
is chanting death to America but they
seem friendly at the same time it's
utterly bizarre just told me to stand to
the side because I'm a woman you're not
the only person who's said that I don't
I just don't know what the difference is
what's happening in this country right
now in the name of religion is so
dangerous
good or something put your mouth over
your nose that why you're in the theater
that is the rule if you don't want to
follow the room
[Applause]
people sitting around you
Chris Harper pays my salary
who do you think you are just put your
mask over your nose
thank you
this is the Reuben report it is April
20th 2023 that's right it's 4 20 if
you're watching this from Manhattan or
any other big blue Democrat City just
walk outside take a deep breath get
stoned to get back in here and watch the
show I want to thank my man Brock for
putting together that little cold open
for us uh that crazy lunatic that you
were watching right there first on The
View and then uh on Broadway lecturing
somebody during covet that is Patty
LuPone who is a Broadway actress somehow
comparing Christians to the Taliban and
what do I often say about these people
once you scratch a tolerant Progressive
you always always guys find a nasty
authoritarian so she's very upset about
the Christians in this country who as uh
from where I sit I find to be probably
the most decent and tolerant people in
the in the whole world and she's very
upset that someone would show up to her
show pay for a ticket and have the mask
a little bit below their nose as she's
spitting and genuflecting and screaming
at them these are just terrible people
uh as always guys we've got a post game
show if you want to join us at the end
of the regular program
reubenreport.locals.com and before I get
to the show today I want to tell you
about a dream I had last night because
it was so bananas yet so connected to
what we do here I it was 4 am I woke up
and I was like I've got to remember this
I have to tell the people this dream
because you maybe you guys can analyze
it because the pieces are right there
but I can't quite figure out what it
what it was so I was at the debate it
was a presidential debate and Joe Biden
was on stage and I think I was in Vegas
like it felt like Vegas to me there was
something vegasy about it and I was in
the front row
Joe Biden was on stage and there was a
big table like a Deus of people but all
the other candidates were just regular
people so it was Joe Biden and a whole
bunch of regular people and I was
sitting in the front row very close to
Joe so he was maybe three feet in front
of me and there was barbecue sauce
pouring out of his nose I kid you'd a
barbecue sauce was just pouring out of
his nose but nobody saw it nobody else
saw it except for me and I was trying to
take pictures with it but my phone
wouldn't take any pictures it wouldn't
let me take pictures of video so I'm
watching the barbecue sauce pour out of
Joe Biden's nose he's standing right in
front of me I can't take a picture and
then he walks backstage and nobody even
notices still he walks backstage and
here's where it really gets weird he
comes back out and he's Joe Biden
wearing a Joe Biden costume and he's
dancing to Oh What a Night by Frankie
Valli in the Four Seasons you know oh
what a night and then everyone on stage
starts dancing to it and then I woke up
like what the hell is that
Joe Biden but what's the barbecue sauce
pouring out of his nose I mean we do
grill a lot around here so it has
something to do with grilling and
smoking Meats a whole bunch of people
not really noticing I guess that
something's wrong with Joe Biden but
then he comes back in a Joe Biden mask
and you know I listen to a lot of
Frankie Valli so like that sort of makes
sense but there's some piece of this
thing help me people please let us know
uh if you're in the the locals comments
right now I'll read a couple of them at
the end during the post game and uh if
you're playing along on YouTube please
join us uh or Rumble if you please join
us on locals and we'll re go through you
can psychologically analyze my dreams
Joe Biden barbecue sauce pouring out of
his nose in a Joe Biden costume dancing
to the Four Seasons my phone wouldn't
work like there's something about that
the picture and the video not working
help me people just help me let's see if
we can figure out the Deep recesses of
my mind
uh on a less enthusiastic note than
barbecue sauce pouring out of Joe
Biden's nose Brian stelter remember him
Mr Potato Head from CNN who got canned
about six months ago and really he had
been in many ways I think I sort of owe
Brian stelter a lot because he made my
job very easy basically I could wake up
every morning and be like Phoenix what
did uh stelter do yesterday and we could
make you know make a program about it
because you know he basically lied about
everything he's a Democrat operative he
still doesn't see why he got fired he
then gets fired from CNN and what
happens when you're a Democrat and you
have Democrat privilege you get actually
moved up the chain and then he ended up
for the last six months he has been
believe it or not a professor of
Journalism because irony is dead at
Harvard which means that there are rich
white people white people who pay like
70 grand a year to have their children
learn about journalism from Brian's
shelter my God if that doesn't give you
brain damage I don't know what will
anyway he's back baby uh he went on Dan
Abrams live Dan Abrams who was once an
MSNBC guy he's done some other things I
I don't know exactly where his show airs
now but he brought stelter on to talk
about what has happened to stelter and I
just thought it will sort of lead us to
a lot of things that are going on uh
with the machine and how some of our
politicians starve the machine some of
our politicians feed the machine and if
you as a leader or a want to be
president let's say rolling into 2024 if
you don't know whether you're supposed
to starve it or feed it or how to behave
accordingly uh it's going to eat you
alive and I think we have a very Stark
and obvious choice when it comes to that
on the Republican side so we're gonna do
all that we're gonna do a Reuben report
uh locals Community Q a and uh and I
don't know maybe much more there's only
one way to find out maybe barbecue sauce
will start pouring out of my notes who
knows but let's talk about relief man
real quick and then we'll get to it you
know guys is Joe Biden's economy making
you nauseous well you got to check out
relief band relief band's the number one
FDA cleared anti-nausea wristband that
has been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraines hangovers
morning sickness and chemotherapy so and
so much more whether you need everyday
nausea relief or just an occasional cure
from nausea their patented technology
makes feeling sick a thing of the past
relief fans 100 drug free and non-drowsy
they've got an A plus Better Business
Bureau rating at over a hundred thousand
satisfied customers so they're a brand
you can trust you guys know I like to
polish off the week with a nice glass of
tequila if I'm a bit nauseous the next
morning it's rare but it happens I'll
just throw on my relief band and the
post hangover nudge is gone so if you
want a band that actually works at
relieving your nausea checkout relief
band we've got an exclusive offer just
for you guys if you go to reliefband.com
use promo code Reuben you'll get 20 off
off plus free shipping and a no question
is asked 30 a day money back guarantee
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com use promo code
Reuben for twenty percent off plus free
shipping and let's bake a potato ladies
and gentlemen Brian stelter after being
away from the television and your
screens for about six or seven months he
returned on Dan Abrams program and he
still doesn't know why he got fired
I want to ask you about leaving CNN
um you recently relatively recently left
CNN
um and clearly they kind of pushed you
out uh as they as they as they announced
they were I've embraced the f word Dan
fired you got fired
um why do you think you got fired I
don't know really you really don't know
I really truly don't know uh yeah I know
I had a popular show by CNN standards
and I know that it was pretty cheap to
produce but I also know every show gets
canceled eventually sorry yeah yeah
knock on table okay yeah every show gets
canceled eventually uh and so I was
content with it
um but I think what CNN's trying to do
is what I just said lower the
temperature lower the volume and I'm
rooting for them because we need to have
a lot of news networks in this country
we need a wide variety of news sources
that are just trying to gather the facts
the CEO Chris Licht has talked about
wanting to emphasize news for example
over opinion right
um and do you think you represented the
kind of opinion particularly from the
left that Chris select wanted to
distance himself from because I think
that's why he ended up letting you go
well I'm just going to let you say it
then yeah I think we were doing really
fantastic journalism at CNN for the nine
years that I was there I also think Fox
News really enjoyed making me a Target
and making you know using horrible names
about me and all that sort of stuff that
happens in the cable news Wars and I
think they enjoyed seeing me uh leave
CNN we think that part of the region
that he got let go was because Fox News
was constantly making fun of him yeah
look that's something that I wonder but
I'm very happy content not knowing
exactly what happened
all right first off I'm going believe it
or not to give stelter a little credit
as Dan Abrams is beginning the thing and
he's like uh you know you parted ways
like he's being signed a kind of soft
shoot with the thing stelter is fully
like yes I got fired so I will give him
credit where credit is due he doesn't
know why he got fired and and you know
Abrams makes the point you know you
probably got fired because you're
obviously a lefty stelter just can't
come around to that he's still at this
point thinks he was let's say fair and
balanced a phrase from another News
Network what he obviously was not he was
a Democrat operative he was a total uh
uh part and parcel of the machine always
giving it what it wants and he was
always getting everything wrong you're
not going to believe this guys but we've
got proof
that would be funny if it wasn't so
Insidious ginning up hate CNN is so much
bigger than any single individual too
much of the U.S media chatter is
distorted to the point of being
dishonest don't be so hateful is that
too much to ask I don't know maybe it is
Trust in Media has CNN lost trust we're
living in two different realities
supported by two different news worlds
it's almost like we need two kinds of
newscasts uh or two versions of the
weather report the forecast is pretty
sunny for the vaccinated but it's quite
Bleak in some states for the
unvaccinated I'm glad that we work in a
building where everyone's vaccinated
looking ahead to 2020 one reason why I'm
taking you seriously as a contender is
because of your presence on cable news
what does the Press get wrong when
covering Biden's agenda when you watch
the news when you read the news what do
you think we get wrong I'm going to go a
little bit uh Rogue here so bear with me
okay Trump's odd behavior with Vladimir
Putin is compelling so many people to
ask what does puta put have on Trump
has Trump been compromised when you see
um entire media companies essentially
exist to tear down Joe Biden is there an
equivalent to that on the left tearing
down Trump reducing a liar's reach is
not the same as censoring freedom of
speech freedom speech is different than
freedom of reach the media organs that
profit from conflict are on a crusade
now working overtime to demonize Disney
claiming the company is indoctrinating
and sexualizing children for through
movies and TV shows sorry just it pisses
me off and
for all we know these emails are made up
or maybe some are real and others are
fakes we don't know but we do know that
this is a classic example of the
right-wing media I want to know which
one you watching this right now laughed
the most that felt was the most
ridiculous because we were all having
different reactions to all of them the
one with the uh you know the there's a
right-wing media trying to destroy his
Trump does that exist on like it's all
so
insane and all of the lies related to
covet and Saki how can we help you more
and like all of the stuff but what he
did not realize was that if you just
give the machine what it wants you are
just a piece of the machine and the
pieces of the machine always have to be
replaced and he was a very replaceable
piece in that machine because if you
don't do something that is true and
unique
then you're very replaceable it's as
simple as that but interestingly his his
little return there uh to to talk about
stelter in a sort of broader sense to
not really making it about him he does
represent something he and and the
people like him the Rachel maddows and
you know all of the the clowns at CNN
and MSNBC and the joy reads and all in
the Don Lemons well you know the cast of
characters they actually do pose a
threat to I would say freedom to Liberty
to conservatism to those of us broadly
speaking on the right because they're
always lying about us and then as we've
been really laying out on the show the
last couple days they demonize people to
the point that we start losing culture
too because then the TV shows are going
against us and the movies are going
against us and then over time what
happens is you have a bunch of young
people growing up not knowing the
differences between boys and girls and
believing the nonsense that they are
hearing on these things so stelter is
the epitome of of what the machine does
to people who don't take a stand don't
be an individual and and fight for
actually what is true now I want to
connect that to something else to to
what's going on uh in the sort of
racehorse politics of 2024 because if
you as one of the candidates do not know
how to properly deal with that machine
then you're actually just going to
strengthen it as it drowns you meaning
if the machine is always lying about you
let's let's take Trump for example if
the machine is always lying about you if
corporate media CNN New York Times blah
blah blah blah blah if they're always
lying about you but you're always
talking about their ratings or you're
always going on their shows and always
attacking them you're actually keeping
them alive you are thus part of the
machine my argument at this point would
be it's not that Donald Trump is part of
the elite in a sense but he is part of
the machine because he feeds the machine
right now to San this is doing something
different he's not feeding the machine
NBC we played a bunch of Clips on this
you guys know this uh he NBC lied about
him so many times and lied about this
ridiculous uh African-American studies
course that they were going to push woke
gender ideology into and then uh what
was it Andrea Mitchell sat down with
Kamala Harris and said to her what is it
that Ron DeSantis doesn't want people to
know about slavery and black history and
civil rights and it was just like one of
those times where they just lie and lie
and lie and lie and finally desantis's
campaign said we're just not talking to
you anymore we're not going to take you
serious anymore so he's starving the
machine I personally think we are at the
point now I think we've been at this
point for quite some time we just don't
know how to fully embrace it I would say
or fully get to the other side of it
where the online media
whether it's Crowder or it's me or it's
Rogan or Shapiro or all of us or
whatever the version of it is on the
left we have so jumped ahead of those
guys in terms of reliability and decency
and something hopefully funny and
amusing and worth your time and all of
those things
that we have to let it go and Trump
keeps feeding it so now I want to show
you just a couple videos here uh this is
DeSantis talking about how much he's
accomplished at governor and sort of how
he's gone about doing it
you know we also just made it very clear
when you're going into executive
position you have to want you're the one
that kind of makes decisions and you got
to make good decisions you know you can
set the agenda and it's all very
important but you just doing that isn't
enough you got to have people in the
administration who share the vision and
who are going to put kind of the agenda
ahead of their own agenda and we just
made it very clear at the beginning
because you can make the decisions if
they're going to act to frustrate your
agenda or they're not carrying out the
agenda then none of this ends up working
out so we said very clearly to people
you know if you're leaking if you're
have bringing a different agenda into
this Administration pack your bags right
now you're gone we're not putting up
with it and the result is is that we've
had over four years we don't leak to the
media there's no Palace Intrigue very
little there's no drama about anything
like behind the scenes all it is is just
daily execution of the mission and
that's the reason why we've been able to
get so much stuff done we don't get
diverted with all the nonsense that's
out there so we set that down on day one
daily execution of the mission you think
he was a lawyer in the Navy what do you
think what do you think anyway the point
is what he's he's saying two things
there you don't feed the media through
leaks right so the Trump Administration
and all administrations Trump had a lot
of them but all administrations have
leaks to the media it's one of the way
ways that the machine always stays in
front of us they have people so Trump
had people in his administration who
were constantly leaking to the New York
Times who were writing bad things then
Trump was fighting them and it becomes
this sort of circular logic
self-fulfilling prophecy situation
DeSantis is saying we simply don't have
that we're making sure we don't hire
people that do that sort of thing so you
starve the Beast right you starve the
Beast and then also you know by Staffing
with the right people leaks aside by
just having the right people beside you
who are not trying to take you out who
are mission aligned who understand what
their roles are who aren't in it for
themselves in a conventional sense but
they are in it because they believe that
the vision of whoever that person is
whether it's a governor or president is
the right vision and they will put their
ego aside to make that happen well
that's what we've got right here but
Trump did not have that that is that is
just simply true this is not me
gratuitously going after Trump he did
not and I think this is one of the
things that we have to think about going
forward right do you want someone that
perhaps again is going to hire you know
basically bring in a whole bunch of
people like John Bolton and all the
people that he then tells you are all
morons and idiots Plus have a whole
staff that is constantly leaking to the
media of us keeping the media alive as
he's always attacking the media we just
have to decide what direction we want to
go in that but interestingly what's
happening with the the Trump DeSantis
situation is that Trump has really
shifted you know a couple weeks ago he
was constantly calling DeSantis a
globalist in a rhino and he just knows
it's not true it's just meaningless like
if if DeSantis is a globalist and a
rhino then is anyone done like if you're
watching this Don is anyone besides you
not a globalist or Rhino if every right
everyone that you are argue with is a
globalist and Rhino in a buffoon and a
okay fine so it's just meaningless
stuff uh this is a guy that he endorsed
twice that he lives in his State and all
that but he's shifted from saying all of
that kind of stuff and basically saying
he's cheating on his wife and like all
the over-the-top stuff now he's just
trying to get him not to run and I think
that that's an interesting shift there
he's realizing that the over-the-top
attacks are not working so notice the
tone change uh here this is from
yesterday
Ron DeSantis is a young man who is not
doing well against me in the polls to
put it mildly I believe that if he
decides to run for president which will
only hurt and somewhat divide the
Republican party which we don't need he
will lose the cherished and massive Mega
vote and never be able to successfully
run for office again I believe that
if he remains Governor which is what
Florida voters assumed he would do
it would be a whole different story just
saying but who knows you really need to
understand guys and this is just the
truth and and look I know a huge
percentage of my audience is on the
Trump 2024 train and again there's a
good chance I'll end up voting for him
and you know all my disclaimers related
to all this but you really need to
acknowledge a truth here which is that
this is the first time we are seeing
Trump absolutely quaking in his boots
afraid of another candidate he did the
attacks on Rubio and he crushed him in
three days he did the attacks on Cruz
and it crushed him in three days now
both of those guys ended up being huge
Trump backers once Trump was President
so a lot of this is just racehorse
politics and everyone should make sure
their feelings aren't too hurt but Trump
has never had a situation like this
where he did all of his you know garbage
attacks on somebody and the over-the-top
name calling and all the other stuff and
got pushed back to the point where now
he's just he's basically begging him not
to run and if you really didn't fear the
guy you wouldn't care if he ran but
notice he's not attacking Nikki Haley
he's not attacking vivec he he's not
attacking Mike Pompeo he's not attacking
Tim Scott or any of the other people
that might get in there but every day
he's going after DeSantis because he
sees I think what I see and what you see
which is that a whole bunch of people a
whole bunch of people are like wait a
minute we're done with the show we want
competency Clarity and communication and
and that basically is uh what DeSantis
is offering we can actually skip my we
were going to show a couple tweets on uh
that I put out about that but I think I
summed it up uh fairly well right there
I'll let you guys be the judge on that
anyway again I don't say all of this to
just add fuel to the fire of the fight
here but I think it is important to to
acknowledge what's actually happening in
real time three weeks ago he was all in
on the crazy over the top over the top
attacks and now he basically uh is is
saying please don't run please don't run
and it's not because I fear you but it's
like yeah it is because you fear him I'm
getting some breaking news right now
this is yeah is this right BuzzFeed
remember BuzzFeed it is shutting down
and going out of business as of today
wow I mean that's great that's great I
mean BuzzFeed became largely irrelevant
over the last five years have we ever
sourced above BuzzFeed article once on
this show but BuzzFeed was sort of at
the nascents of the internet when
remember every everything seemed cool on
the internet what are your five favorite
version colors of blue and what are the
five favorite vegetables you like and do
you like butts more than breasts or and
we would they were basically data mining
everybody to see overall our habits so
God only knows what they what
information they stole from us on their
way out the door but watching a thing
like them collapse is uh quite good and
oh I would say also a good sign for all
the independent creators out there uh on
that note let's get to the
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
Rimfire says why is the T part of the
LGB anyway who added the t is it because
of its letters I don't see see what the
T has to do with the LGB anyway one is
about sexual attraction for males or
females or either tea is about not
feeling comfortable in the body you are
born into what are your thoughts you are
completely completely right I actually
tweeted something about this uh this
morning the t's have nothing to do with
the L's or the G's or the bees there is
a stark difference between sexual
orientation and having a disconnect
between your psychological State and
your physical body I have no more in
common
as a gay person I have no more in common
with a trans person than you as a
straight person I I don't I'm not
disassociated from my own body I am not
trying to change my body in any way
right I'm not trying to deny biology in
any way I think that's really the the
key part of this thing now somebody may
be watching this and be like well I
don't like gays I don't like the idea
that you can be attracted to the same
sex and blah blah blah okay but I'm
first off I'm not asking anyone it's
permission to live my life right I want
equality of nothing else but the way
they have combined these things and I
think you can even go a step further the
t's are actually actively at odds with
the L's and the G's and the B's because
it is the teas that want a young
potentially lesbian girl who is let's
say 12 years old who maybe is a bit more
of a tomboy and likes playing softball
and getting out there with the guys
they're the ones who want to chop her
breasts off and transform her into a boy
right it is the tease who want to take
the young effeminate boy who maybe likes
art and music more than you know video
games and and you know GI Joe and turn
him into a girl so they are there is no
group of people at odds more with the
gays than the t's this is a huge problem
I have I hate the I also hate the phrase
Community like there is no Community I
have a couple gay friends I don't think
they're better or worse because they're
gay that's it I don't think people are
walking around uh hopefully choosing me
as a friend based on that it's it's just
absolutely utterly irrelevant and you
are you are much more than your body
parts believe it or not
says isn't it ironic that some people
have fled other countries to come to the
United States to get away from socialism
and communism now some people are
fleeing other states so they can get
away from what the Democrats have done
to some of these states of which they
are fleeing sort of like socialism and
communism you know I can tell you very
clearly being here in Miami where we
obviously have a huge uh Latino not
latinx Community imagine walking up to
like my my Cuban Gardener being like are
you latinx ridiculous Rolando if you're
watching I love you
um
being here in Miami where we have a lot
of Cubans obviously we have Venezuelans
there's just such an interesting Vibrant
Community here
um the Cubans especially because Cuba is
so close obviously to Florida I mean the
endless stories of flea and Castro and
everything else whatever generation
immigrant you are they have such a love
of Freedom it is so absolutely
spectacular as a matter of fact last
week I spoke to the young Republicans of
Miami at Calle Ocho which is a legendary
uh Cuban bar that was founded probably I
don't know maybe four decades ago by a
Cuban Refugee and they have all his
artwork that he had to send on a boat
from Cuba and the boat sank and it's
like a whole bunch of crazy stuff but a
lot of the young Republicans are Cuban
and it was just great to be around
people uh that just have freedom is in
them they know what's in them and
unfortunately what happens is in these
blue States you get often it is the
liberal white person who's five seven
generations American who has no idea
what their ancestors fled anymore uh
that starts importing the very ideas
that their ancestors were indeed fleeing
it is ironic and ridiculous Nick says
did Tyrus reach out to you after your
interview with Kat timff to assure you
that he does not actually hate you so
for those of you that have not seen the
interview yet we just put it up my
interview with gutfeld's co-host Kat
timp and as you guys know the other
co-host is Tyrus Tyrus and I I've always
felt there's some sort of tension there
one night we did years ago me and Tyrus
and Gutfeld and a couple other the
guests and some producers went out and
we got into a majorly heated political
debate it's not even important what it
was about but it was hot like like at
the end it was almost like people
getting up and and you know fist
clenching
that was sort of uh the end of me and
Tyrus kind of hanging like that but when
I do the show I always just get the
impression that he hates me but then
we'd go ahead and do the show
um and uh I guess if I had to fight him
I could I could probably body slam that
guy what do you think yeah thank you
Phoenix I could definitely body no
Connor no you can't body slam tires well
I would try I would probably get a
hernia that would that would be an
automatic hernia you know that would not
be good uh cam says have you thought
about interviewing Robert F Kennedy Jr
he's been on several podcasts uh but
don't know if he's been on any Lefty
media Outlets so Robert F Kennedy Jr
obviously from the Kennedy family he has
been basically the most outspoken public
person against vaccines mandates the the
pharmaceutical industrial complex the
whole freaking thing have we reached out
to him I think we I think he was on our
Master list all right we're gonna follow
up on that let's follow up on that today
for sure
I would love to have him on I guarantee
you one thing guys there is zero and I
mean zero not white supremacy zero I
mean regular old zero chance that they
will let Biden get on a debate stage
with him you know he Biden is obviously
the presumptive nominee uh what could be
interesting is if the if Biden actually
had the the mental collapse that we all
know he's sort of already had but if
they if they really were pushing him out
of the way and they're going to try to
figure out how to have Gavin LeapFrog
Kamala well then he might be able to
force his way into some sort of debate
or something
um but I don't understand and I and one
of the reasons I love to interview him
uh is I don't understand what makes him
a Democrat at this point other than that
his name is Kennedy he doesn't as far as
I can tell believe in these big
government programs he does see the
media the way we see the media I would
love to explore that a little more
because that's a rich thing and it's
also tactically it seems odd to me
because if he right this moment if he
just switched his party affiliation
there was a pretty damn good chance he
ends up on a debate stage the first
Republican debate is in August he will
end up on that stage like you only need
you know a couple percentage points to
get on that stage so why not jump in as
a Republican and then and then you could
still sell your Democrat policies and
maybe it won't go that well but at least
you get out there so there's some
tactical stuff that I'd like to talk
about with him so yes we will definitely
follow up on that
crafty cat says what are your favorite
things to grow in your garden you know
about three weeks ago it's very
difficult to grow uh tomatoes in Florida
that's one thing that I found because of
the humidity and the heat tomatoes need
a little more moving air and it's been
tough but I planted three very very baby
tomato plants that I got at Home Depot
no I planted four of them actually like
this size they are blooming right now we
got tons and tons of tomatoes out there
and they're feeling good we've had a lot
of rain lately so I think that's good
and I you know one of the tips that I
got from somebody was that if you really
keep them slim and trim so that the air
can get through so you don't want them
too bushy you don't want them too leafy
you're going to be able to keep them
alive a little bit longer that can
sometimes be a bit of a catch-22 because
if the Sun is beating down all day you
do want some leaves to defray the
sunshine so you're not burning the
tomatoes but I'm out there we've also
got a mango tree that's doing really
well right now we've got two bushels of
bananas on the way so if monkey pox
comes back I've got plenty of bananas
for everybody uh what else do we have
out there we've got some basil out there
and I have this other area that I
actually want to talk to my in Rolando
about who I mentioned earlier I want to
talk to them about today about building
out a bigger Garden situation but one
thing that's nice about Florida it's
like because of the rain because of that
everything wants to grow here everything
wants to be alive oh we have a huge
avocado tree also
um you know things just things just
flourish here like Freedom Lynn says
what do you think about the Republican
candidate whoever it turns out to be
talking oh sorry taking Robert Kennedy
Jr as his running mate because you know
they're going to pull a Bernie Sanders
on Kennedy and install a certain lizard
person so the lizard person you're
talking about is Gavin Newsom you're
probably right if it's not Joe Biden
Kamala they're going to just how ironic
it's the Democrats that are going to
keep the black woman out of the Oval
Office like it's so perfect mwah I
respect you people for your evil
um that would be interesting that would
be interesting maybe you know what I'll
even have a little asterisk next to my
previous answer which is that maybe
that's his move maybe his move right now
is to try to get through the Democrat
machine knowing how corrupt that thing
is how evil they're going to treat him
they'll never let him get on a debate
stage but a whole bunch of people will
start hearing his ideas one way or
another then
let's say it's the scientist then
DeSantis running through now doesn't
have this you've got the conservatives
you've got the Libertarians you got the
right-leaning people you hopefully work
it out with Trump in some way and then
you're like who could I have behind me
that would be good that might perhaps
soften the ticket a little bit because
he's a Democrat ooh how we really got
something and then you got Robert F
Kennedy Jr who's freaking pissed at the
Democrats too but can maybe bring you
those disaffected liberals who who wrote
that comment Who's whose comment was
that
that was Lynn Lynn I will give you
credit for this one if it happens you
you were the first one to pop the idea
in my mind you will be given credit
accordingly you get nothing else besides
credit but that's pretty good Kevin
proud Texan I like that says how many
lives could be saved if the government
worked as hard to keep fentanyl out of
the country as they did keeping
Ivermectin and hcq out of the country
man I mean
if you don't care
about illegal immigration in terms of
you just don't care how many people come
here at the very least you should care
because of the fentanyl situation we
know we know China is pushing fentanyl
into America to in essence destroy our
cities and they're doing it by because
we have an open porous Border in the
South it is simply that true period so
even if you're sort of
um squishy on immigration you're just
like I don't want a wall and people
should come here you know okay okay we
should give them stuff and everything
else you should care about Americans
dying because of this stuff and you know
the thing with fentanyl you you take
fentanyl once you could die it's also
being laced into all sorts of things on
this 420 it's being laced into marijuana
it's being laced into these other drugs
and again I don't welcome you to do it
but I would say just watch a video of
what's going on in San Francisco and see
what fentanyl can do to a society
there's more than one way to win a war
right you used to have to win a war with
an invasion you used to win a war with
an Army on the ground you don't anymore
maybe you could just drug a country to
the point of of Oblivion to the point
that its cities are are failing uh and
actually there's history there's little
history on this right this is what the
British did to China 500 years ago with
Heroin which a lot of people are saying
is now this is China's payback you could
do a little Googling on that it's
actually a theory that people have right
now uh Oak says Anheuser-Busch has lost
3 billion in value since Bud like woke
controversy began at the start of the
month does anyone get fired I heard it
was about 7 billion in market cap but
but the market may have readjusted
already or something
um does anyone get fired probably not
because once wokism is in these
companies the problem is that you start
hiring so many woke people that if you
fire one everyone else will try to take
your company down from the inside this
is very much what Elon Musk had to deal
with that Twitter now he's he's a unique
personality who is willing uh to to take
the hits on that and 80 percent of the
people who worked the Twitter before he
bought it are now gone I don't know that
Anheuser-Busch could deal with that but
they have seriously screwed themselves I
think this is the type of uh I don't
even want to call it a boycott I think
this is the type of movement that will
stick people have just had it with this
whoa crap and if you would have said to
somebody three years ago you know Bud
Light is going to be sponsoring this
cartoon character of a woman who's
actually a man you would have been like
what the hell are you talking about Bud
Light like Bud Light is for frat guys to
drink while they're being held upside
down by their friends over a keg right
like that's what it's for right Connor
yes
that's what it's for right Daphne yes
that's what it's for not for the trans
person who who again there might have
been some version of this that could
have worked like some little nod to gay
history month or whatever the hell they
call it pride month there might have
been some way to do it by the way
they've been doing it for years I'm
pretty sure Anheuser-Busch and Bud Light
they all sponsor all the gay parades and
everything and everyone kind of sucked
it up no pun intended but once you went
this far with this person who is a
cartoon character of a woman the worst
caricature of a woman you could possibly
come up with people have had enough I
think it's going to stick and there are
plenty of other great beers out there
Mickey says what's your favorite car
that you've ever owned and why you know
I mean the easy answer I I have this
Tesla Model X this is our second one we
we've leased them so we had a three-year
lease and now we're in the midst of we
updated the car and we're in our second
three-year lease
um I I like the idea of sort of getting
the newer update every year uh it's not
it's obviously not the cheapest way to
do it and with the Tesla it's probably
not the smartest way to do it because
Tesla's the Teslas of five years ago are
still going hot on the market it's very
hard to get new cars and like people
still want the Teslas of five years ago
and everything else so buying it would
have probably been a better financial
decision but if you have not driven in a
Tesla it really it is so cool and smooth
and the screen is All Digital and
everything about it feels right I have
never once
I know I can correct that only one time
have I ever had to take the Tesla in for
service it wasn't even an issue that I
was having in the car they they had like
a generic Tesla update uh but even the
way they do that is incredible you drive
the car to a parking lot that was about
10 minutes from my house you leave the
car there you don't even see a human and
then they then somehow once you leave
your car there your car knows that it's
there they text you a credit on Uber uh
so that you can get a car ride home so
you don't even have to pay for that and
they give you another credit the next
day so you can go back to the parking
lot and pick up your car and you don't
even see a person like the whole
operation is so smooth and clean and and
the car is just brilliant you know you
got the front the front trunk because
there's no engine in there it's just
it's just absolutely beautiful I know
it's uh I know it's pricey
um but I really do think it's worth it
uh Smithy says read the Connor Theory
does Conor have a theory about Zoe
Zephyr the transgender Montana
representative featured on Wednesday
Wednesday's live stream before I throw
it to Connor if you did not see the show
the other day Connor's been throwing
around a theory for a while that the
reason that Leah Thomas is beating all
of these girls in these swimming races
is because as far as we know Leah Thomas
still has a penis and Conor's theory has
been that Leah Thomas is using the penis
as some kind of propeller okay so he's
getting an extra boost of speed using
the propeller so Connor do you have an
answer to that question do you think
that Zoho and Zoe was the trans was the
guy who's now a woman who there you go
who told a bunch of Republicans that
they will have blood on their hands
because they are not allowing for minors
to be transitioned ironically of course
it's the Doctor Who chops off a child's
genitals who has blood on his hands
literally but I know again irony is dead
do you have a theory related to this in
any way Connor
his dress designer has blood on his
hands look at you with a little sass
little sassy Connor today hot damn Nate
says Dave do you think the majority of
the backlash against Anheuser-Busch is
just about them sponsoring a trans
person or does it have more to do with
this specific trans person oh I I guess
I jumped ahead on that one yeah I think
there was a way to have they've all been
doing this Banks beer companies
everybody's sponsors Pride this blah
blah blah it's June oh my God yeah yeah
we're dancing with sparkles
and people and nobody cares right nobody
really cares they all pretend to care
but nobody really cares uh this had I
think specifically to do with this
person I I don't care for Dylan Mulvaney
one way or another uh but Dylan Mulvaney
chose to to transition again we don't
even know about the full surgeries but
then become the worst stereotype of a
woman a shopping obsessed woman the the
affect that he or she speaks with all of
those things so I think it had more to
do with the specific person and also
this moment in time you know we're
getting some wins against the woke right
like the the DeSantis Disney thing is
the best thing well school choice
happening all over the country right now
that's a good thing too but we're
getting some wins and I think people are
starting it's what I'm always talking
about on the show you start getting some
wins and then you might start standing
up straight with your shoulders back you
might start going for more wins and I
think they just poked the bear one too
many times uh Olivia says your
enthusiasm for the sunshine state is
inspiring my husband and I live in
Philadelphia I'm trying to convince him
to move to Florida we're taking an
exploratory trip soon he works in the
world of wine and is very accomplished
he would need to find a good job any
advice is helpful as to locations to
visit slash move work etc so I'm glad I
came across your channel months ago I
love it thanks for what to do well first
off I hope you can make it happen one
way or another I do not know anyone that
has regretted moving to Florida I meet
new Floridians literally every day
whether it's walking the dog or at the
store or wherever I am
and it you'll you'll see you come down
here and it's not just like I'm in Miami
Miami is obviously a very hot City but
rumbles in Sarasota you know I spend
time on the on the Southwest uh Coast
um you know like you go anywhere in
Florida the strip malls are all packed
there is business happening people are
out and about the restaurants are all
packed like you don't see uh just five
stores in a row that are closed you
rarely see one store that's closed uh I
will tell you this it's going to be
tough to find a house because so many
people are moving here and house prices
are high uh but hopefully you'll figure
it out and you know they're working on
on a whole bunch of infrastructure
projects escalating them to make uh
building easier and faster and all that
kind of stuff as far as your husband's
in wine I'm going to do some thinking on
this I'm gonna do some thinking on this
actually one thing I've been thinking as
long as we're talking about booze for a
moment is I really want to start my own
tequila I've gotta I just everyone's got
George Clooney's got a tequila who is
the guy that we drank his tequila the
other day Kevin Hart's got his own
tequila I feel like everybody's got
their own tequila who else uh Brandon
Schwab has a tequila
he's got a whiskey everyone's got
something Dave rubin's gonna have a Dave
Rubin tequila and I'm gonna tell you
this tequila is gonna be good and it's
going to be clean and it's going to be
reasonably priced we're looking at about
35 bucks okay patience 35 bucks you like
the 35 bucks all right we're gonna make
it happen uh stay tuned on that and good
luck to you guys and if I can help in
any way let me know how uh Elizabeth
says since we just finished tax season
what are you hoping your tax dollars
fund I know I'm hoping it goes with
something worthwhile like paying bribes
or funding foreign gender programs yeah
I really hope that mine are able to fund
as many poor Mexican children having
their wangs lopped off that's what I'm
really hoping for
um no you know it's funny I sat down
with my business manager yesterday and
we were going through our some tax stuff
and we were going through our
three-month budget since being here and
when I look at those numbers and just
see like what I would be paying to be
living in California right now versus
here and that everything works here you
know they've got everybody so Bamboozled
about the state income tax tax they've
got us bamboos with about taxes in
general and federal income tax and
everything else here's where I can go on
a real libertarian high horse in this
situation but everything in Florida is
working better than everything in Cali
and we don't have state income tax how
is it that we're able to fund our
schools how is it that our roads are not
collapsing how is it that everything's
working here and nothing's working there
do you think maybe it's not exactly
about the money amount of money you take
in it's about the amount of money you
spend do you think that might be it and
if you live within your means not only
you as a person but the state you live
in that things can actually get better
so I I really was like I ended the
meeting yesterday I was like I am never
I mean I said I'm obviously not going
back to Cali but it was like
Lloyd says with all the activities
family and business any chance the third
book of the trilogy will happen this
year or early next
I am so freaking busy right now I think
I mentioned once I've sketched out the
the basic idea for the third book and
once we did you know it was don't burn
this book don't burn this country you
can kind of think as to what the title
of the next one might be and I I do have
a way of sort of I think bringing it all
together it's it's very much in line
with some of the things that I've been
talking about over the last week or so
related to culture and politics and and
our behavior when you live in a system
that seemingly is always going to drag
you sort of what you can do so it's a
little bit of an extension off the
middle book I just right now I am the
time situation is just really freaking
tough you know maybe I think my best bet
is we're going to try to figure out the
off the great August situation but the
refer the first Republican debate is
during August and Rumble is the official
live streamer no YouTube so I'm gonna
have to be there we don't know the date
yet I'm hoping it's early August and
then I get to do some Off the Grid later
August that's where I could really start
expanding on it a little bit more but I
would say
I mean it takes a while to write and
publish we're probably looking at 2025
probably we'll see we'll see uh Tony
says which of your staff probably gets
the worst targeted ads as a result of
the Google searches that you have them
perform that's interesting I feel like
uh well I usually go to Connor for the
for the drugs and the booze for some
reason then I who am I going I feel like
Brock I'm usually going to you on Whose
Wang has been chopped off so I feel like
you probably have the worst of all the
ads right like when you're at home
you're getting some pretty pretty bad
stuff yeah I've had you Daphne you've
Googled a couple times
um I hope you all have ad blockers
that's the point right like it ain't
pretty it ain't pretty I'll tell you
something speaking of tech has have any
of you had this I tweeted this out
yesterday but maybe you guys even here
have had this I just noticed that a
whole bunch of my uh iMessages that
people that I've had long conversations
with Phoenix the one that I have with
you and the one that I have with you and
Daphne my that we've had these
conversations going for years at this
point gone I have a new thread that
started out of nowhere have you had that
too really so what the hell is that all
about
really weird
weird
ghosts in the machine or the government
government in the machine I'm pretty
sure that's what we mean uh guys if you
haven't subscribed yet jump over to
rumble.com Ruben report and uh give us a
little tap on that green thing over
there uh part two of my interview with
legendary oscar-winning actor Richard
Dreyfus is up right now we leave you
with a cold close of Eric swalwell being
smacked down and we've got a post game
show at about 36 seconds see you there
our rhetoric and to denounce
anti-Semitism and anti-police rhetoric
in this country so that Jewish Americans
and police officers can be safer
Congressman I do thank you and I go back
the gentleman yields and now I recognize
the gentlelady from Georgia Miss Green
that was quite entertaining from someone
that had a sexual relationship with a
Chinese spy and everyone knows it
what
[Music]